most film productions shoot far more
footage than we ever see and the stuff
we do get to see on the big screen is
usually there for a pretty good reason
but when the final edits are made some
deleted scenes are sorely missed from
the movies they were cut from they might
add extra layers to the characters and
their stories provide humorous breaks
and dramatic action or even give the
audience a fascinating new perspective
on the plot itself but these are not
those scenes no these cinematic mistakes
were better off left on the cutting room
floor a dark turn the Back to the Future
movies were never supposed to be
anything but Cracker Jack wholesome
family fun so it's easy to see why this
particular scene in part 3 ended up in
the trash early on in the movie Buford
tannins gang faced off with the local
marshal and his young son after
disarming the marshal Tannen orders him
to leave town he does but Tannen shoots
him in the back anyway right in front of
the boy discipline while this might have
been in keeping with canons ruthless
detestable character it would have been
a shocking departure from the trilogy's
light-hearted tone ant-man wins big
Scott Lang's desire to turn away from
crime and become a suitable role model
for his young daughter Cassie was one of
ant-man's principal character arcs so
it's no surprise then that this scene
didn't make the cut it featured Scott's
buddies Kurt Lewis and Dave indulging in
a night out at a casino consistently
getting lucky with the help of a certain
diminutive hero
[Music]
it's an entertaining sequence but given
Scott's steadfast insistence on turning
over a new leaf it wouldn't have made a
whole lot of sense in the context of the
movie had Lee's lost hope in James
Cameron's 1986 masterpiece aliens
Sigourney Weaver's Ellen Ripley returns
to the moon lv-426 to make contact with
a lost human colony accompanied by a
ragtag band of Space Marines Ripley
finds the colony deserted in half
destroyed resulting in some of the Alien
sagas darkest and most unsettling scenes
noting the movie's original cut however
included another scene which
single-handedly put an end to all the
tension and terror of the abandoned
Hadleys hope here we meet the
inhabitants of the colony as they go
about their day complete with lengthy
unnecessary static shots and a walk and
talk conversation between two characters
which adds almost zero substance to the
plot
[Music]
we also meet newt and her family before
the scene concludes with the movies
first appearance of a face hugger all in
all it amounts to an arduous useless
bout of exposition which would have
drained pretty much all of the suspense
from the movies terrifying second act
judgment revoked the ending to
Terminator 2 Judgment Day is the perfect
coda to a grim thrilling sci-fi
adventure the audience's point of view
traverses a dark mysterious road while a
weary Sarah Connor muses on the
ambiguity of the future before allowing
herself a brief final glimmer of hope
for humanity's faith James Cameron's
original ending however was a little
less ambiguous we see an elderly Sarah
sitting in a park while an adult John
Connor plays with his daughter Sarah
states flatly into a tape recorder the
Judgment Day has been and gone August
29th 1997 came and went
nothing much happened Michael Jackson
turned 40 she then makes a few comments
on humanity's future which you might
recognize from the final cut fade to
black
roll credits it's far too tidy and
ending and totally unsuitable for the
movie it's supposed to wrap up then
again it wouldn't have left much room
for a sequel either which may not have
been the worst thing in the world a
grievous error the showdown between
obi-wan Kenobi and his wheezing alien
nemesis General Grievous was one of
Revenge of the Sith SMO Stentor taining
sequences according to a discarded
animatic for the scene however the fight
almost ended in the most ridiculous way
possible the scene would have played out
largely the same right up to the moment
that Kenobi manages to partially pry
open Grievous's protective chest plate
rather than getting cold cocked and
nearly falling to his death
Kenobi would have finished Grievous off
by tearing out its heart with his bare
hands casually tossing it aside and
blasting it with his sidearm
somehow managing to be both way too dark
and cartoonish at the same time the very
fact that this scene was cut from the
movie is quantifiable proof that George
Lucas is sometimes capable of discarding
bad ideas not quite getting out at the
climax of Jordan peels masterpiece get
out protagonists Chris Washington
finally escapes the grip of the
nefarious Armitage family as he barely
restrains himself from strangling Rose
his ex-girlfriend and pursuer a police
car arrived
knowing nobody could possibly believe
his story Chris prepares to be arrested
or worse but it's a fake out the car is
driven by Chris's tsa buddy rod who
helps Chris make good his escape in the
movies original ending however it really
is the police who arrived and Chris has
promptly arrested and taken to jail stop
a Stockton although it might have made
for a more realistic conclusion to the
plot peels decision to give the
beleaguered Chris a happy ending seems
like it was for the best
clerks last shot Kevin Smith's 1994
debut feature is a largely plot free
film which found most of its comedic
mileage in the reference Laden dialogue
of its slacker leads it's a slight
sardonic work in which almost nothing
happens which would have made its
alternate ending not only shocking but
completely inappropriate in the original
ending Dante is closing up the store
after Randall leaves a man approaches
the counter and Dante informs him that
they're closed only to be shot dead on
the spot as the man cleans out the
register the movie ends with a close-up
on Dante's lifeless body Smith claimed
that he shot this ending simply because
he had no idea how to end the movie but
fortunately star Brian O'Halloran who
hated the sequence was able to convince
him to cut it
thank goodness or the film might not
have become the cult classic it is today